The cast of American Pickers is known for
finding treasures inside mountains of garbage.
And just like the Pickers themselves, we've
scrounged through the lives of Mike Wolfe,
Frank Fritz, and Danielle Colby, as well as
some of their more notable guests. Sit back
and enjoy some behind-the-scenes facts from
American Pickers. You won’t even have to
get your hands dirty.
They have humble beginnings
The art of finding a valuable item in a pile
of junk isn't something that can be learned
overnight. It takes years of practice to hone
those trashy skills, and Mike Wolfe definitely
has plenty of practice. His passion for junk
started during his childhood, after he sold
a bike he found for $5. From there, he began
lurking in alleyways and derelict houses hoping
to find anything worth a couple of bucks.
He also made a habit of harassing farmers
until they let him look through their barns
for old bicycles, which he bought for $50
and sold for up to $5,000. Quite the racket.
Frank, on the other hand, was a building inspector
before he signed on with longtime friend Mike.
So, while his interest was casual, it hit
hard once the show started to film.
Mike is an author
There's always the danger that some more curious
vocations will become a lost art. Well, Mike
Wolfe has already taken action to make sure
that doesn't happen to picking. First, Wolfe
penned Kid Pickers: How to Turn Junk into
Treasure, a children's tome on how to do what
he does. He also started a website with the
same name, providing little pickers with a
social media outlet and community to keep
them all connected. Looks like Wolfe's got
a little junk army forming.
Mike doesn’t want to be a star
Despite all the fame Wolfe and company have
gained since American Pickers captured American
hearts, he doesn't think they deserve it.
According to Wolfe, the real stars are the
eclectic characters, like Hippie Tom, Hobo
Jack, and Prince Mongo, who allow the pickers
to root through their belongings in search
of gold. Wolfe goes on to say that viewers
remember the people, not what was bought from
them. Wolfe remarked in an interview with
Entrepreneur.com, "it's always been an honor
that people open their homes and their hearts
to us." Quite the honor.
Mike doesn’t seem to have too many skeletons
in his closet. Well, except for this one:
"Hahahahaha!"
Frank, on the other hand...
Frank Fritz was taken to court
One of the criticisms of American Pickers
is that they basically rip people off by buying
things cheap so they can sell them for a huge
profit. It other words, capitalism. It didn't
help when Frank Fritz was sued for allegedly
swindling a South Carolina man named Jerry
Bruce. The collector needed a polarimeter
for a museum he wanted to open, he offered
to buy one from the Pickers, since he saw
them purchase one on their show. Fritz offered
to sell it to him for $300, but after Bruce
sent his check, he never got his purchase,
nor was the check cashed. Bruce took Fritz
to court, and Fritz wound up losing the case
by simply not showing up. Ultimately, Bruce
was awarded $1000 for an investment of zero
dollars, which is a deal even the Pickers
would be envious of.
Danielle wears more than one hat
Ever the entrepreneur, American Pickers’
Danielle Colby doesn't limit herself to picking
through junk. Before she gained fame on the
History Channel hit series, she earned a living
by working as a burlesque dancer, which she
continues to do. But she doesn't just dance.
Her devotion to this art form is such that
she's also produced a documentary focusing
on Tempest Storm, a legendary dancer with
a career that spans decades. For a time, Danielle
also owned a little boutique of her own, 4
Miles 2 Memphis, which was located not far
from American Pickers headquarters, and is
also a former roller derby competitor.
Danielle may also be a tax dodger
Perhaps because she has her hands in so many
vocations, Colby's had a habit of forgetting
to give Uncle Sam his cut of the action. Back
in 2013, the IRS informed Colby that she owed
just under $6,000 in unpaid taxes from her
boutique. And that was just her first notice.
Over the next couple of years, she received
at least four more warnings. By 2015, she
reportedly hadn't paid any of the money she
owed, which continued to snowball, even though
she clearly understands business. Let's hope
her other business ventures are squared away.
Hobo Jack is an author too
World renowned hobo and American Pickers regular
"Hobo Jack" Sophir isn't any ordinary hobo.
He's published three books, including the
classic Amazing Adventures of the Tramp Prince.
In addition to his literary ambitions, Backwoods
Jack, as he's also known, fancies himself
a musician. Playing guitar and piano by ear,
Jack has released five albums. According to
his website, since he handles the orders himself,
it could take "weeks or months" for orders
to be fulfilled. Get your copies now!
Prince Mongo has political aspirations
Though he only appeared on the show once,
Robert "Prince Mongo" Hodges is quite unforgettable,
as the residents of his hometown know all
too well:
"I've come to Earth, to save the Earthlings."
When we met the Memphis resident, he dwelled
within a crumbling castle that he called Ashlar
Hall. As the King of Zambodia, he gave away
his castle in 2014 to businessman Kenny Medlin.
The only problem was that he’d kinda already
given it to someone else first, resulting
in a complicated legal situation. He's also
run for mayor numerous times since 1991:
"May the good spirits be with you! All the
way!"
People have tried to cash in on "Mole Man"
Ron's fame
"Mole Man" Ron appeared in one episode of
American Pickers' first season, during which
the guys crawled through his insane burrow
hoping to find some goodies. The purple-hooded
Marty Feldman lookalike gained enough fame
that someone else attempted to cash in on
it. In June of 2011, an ad was posted on Yard
Sales Pittsburgh promoting a sale featuring
items from the Mole Man's burrow. Mole Man
himself wasn't listed as an attendee, but
the ad did mention he'd be stopping by from
time to time. It's very possible that almost
everyone who went to this sale "just missed
him."
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which dark secrets you think the American
Pickers are hiding...